some people hear they want to see fewer  restrictions especially for students  this group here they were protesting in  front of the federal courthouse prior to  a hearing today seagal chada and joey  gilbert both running for nevada state  offices they filed a suit against the  clark county school district to remove  the mask mandates from schools  protesters say they want the right to  choose to wear a mask or take the  vaccine  i support choice  and informed consent which is not what  people are getting  i feel that the government is doing an  overreach by not  being truthful on  the difference between emergency use and  a full fda approval  the group says they will hold more  demonstrations against mandates at the  southern nevada health district and  schools around the valley